hi I'm Kristen Goodwin on this episode
of the Fox News rundown vice president
Mike Pence sits down with Fox's John
Decker to discuss his role as the head
of the coronavirus task force and plans
to reopen the country also election day
is just over six months away Fox News
Sunday host Chris Wallace joins host
Chris Foster to discuss how he feels the
pandemic and sexual assault allegations
against former Vice President Joe Biden
could impact the race to the White House
Plus commentary from guy Benson host of
the guy Benson show the Fox News rundown
is a Daily News podcast where we take a
deeper look at the stories important to
you you can subscribe on your favorite
podcast player by going to FoxNews
podcast.com I'm Sandra Smith I'm Bret
Baier I means lay your heart and this is
the Fox News rundown
Friday May 1st 2020 I'm John Decker vice
president Mike Pence says he's confident
about the White House's plan to combat
the coronavirus rebuild our economy and
restore some normalcy to everyday life
our primary objective is to get America
safely back open get America back to
work and put the coronavirus in the past
I'm Chris Foster Fox News Sunday host
Chris Wallace says about the corona
virus outbreak and the presidential
election maybe it comes down to that do
I have confidence that this is the guy I
want to leave the country and then
handle any particular crisis over the
next four years and Lord knows we don't
have any idea what those will be
and I'm guy Benson I've got the final
word on the Fox News rundown
it's been over two months since the
White House established the coronavirus
task force at first their focus was on
preventing and containing the spread of
kovat 19 and helping hospitals cope with
the unprecedented health crisis in
recent weeks after seeing progress on
that front and seeing signs that social
distancing efforts have flattened the
curves in many parts of the country the
task force has since pivoted working on
plans to safely reopen America's economy
which has been devastated by strict
stay-at-home mandates and
recommendations Vice President Mike
Pence heads the White House coronavirus
task force and I spoke to him after he
toured an Indiana GM plant that is now
manufacturing ventilators the vice
president says America has come a long
way I just couldn't be more inspired by
the workforce here by the ingenuity you
think one month ago this was an empty
factory 17 days they they stood up a
ventilator manufacturing line thanks to
that great entrepreneurial company
Ventech and General Motors they worked
with our administration president Trump
used defense production act to secure
supplies to be able to produce they
stood up the plant in 17 days three days
later they produced their first
ventilator and in one month 600
ventilators are in hospitals and health
care facilities around the country and
these people said it well one team one
mission one month but this is one
amazing group of Americans but they're
not alone I was at GE healthcare a week
ago in Wisconsin and the same speed and
collaboration producing ventilators Ford
Motor Company is also working you see
the whole of America response the
President Trump has marshaled in
connection with coronavirus epidemic and
you come and see it here at the ground
level with hardworking Americans it's
it's just I couldn't be more proud this
is a very pivotal day in a sense that
guidelines are expiring that you were
promoting pretty much every day inside
the White House press
room you were a governor and having that
experience what type of advice would you
give to the nation's governors in terms
of opening up their economies right now
well let me say that no one wants to
open up America again more than
President Donald Trump and our
administration is working very closely
with states around the country to to
implement the guidelines for opening up
America that we issued the rough better
part of two weeks ago thirty-one states
as we speak today have unveiled plans to
reopen their economies we believe in
more will follow soon but the reason why
we're in that position is because 45
days ago at the president's direction
our coronavirus task force worked with
our best scientists to release
guidelines to slow the spread and the
American people put it into practice
and when you look at the guidance that
we're giving States to reopen and in
three different phases this economy
you'll see all of those social
distancing recommendations focus on the
vulnerable population personal hygiene
best business practices they're all
incorporated in that plan as well and
we're very encouraged to see states
around the country not only beginning to
move toward reopening but but reopening
in a safe and responsible way give me a
sense mr. vice president about whether
you believe states all around the
country are prepared as far as testing
kits are concerned testing for
coronavirus well we we have been scaling
testing at a level no other country in
the world has done since the outset of
the corona virus epidemic it truly is
remarkable to think that we're more than
six million tests performed all across
the country when the better part of a
month ago we had just a little bit more
than 80,000 tests it's because the
president brought together like you saw
here in Indiana today private industry
commercial laboratories who developed
new testing platforms and
and and created the kind of
collaboration that's made it possible
for us to expand testing rapidly now we
we believe today every state in America
has the capacity to do the testing that
we recommend needs to be done for phase
one reopening but we're literally
working around the clock with governor's
in all 50 states and our territories to
continue to expand testing so that as we
continue to reopen and as businesses
begin to implement their own policies
that that will have will have a
sufficient amount of testing but we've
we are literally on track to be doing
more than two million tests a week in
the month of May and that's a great
tribute to American ingenuity and the
leadership of President Donald Trump
let's talk a little bit mr. vice
president about the economic impacts and
we all know this that the economy has
just been battered I know the president
is an optimist you're an optimist too
about turning this around by the third
fourth quarter of this year but we just
saw these numbers about the number of
Americans filing for unemployment claims
3.8 million now up to 30 million over
the past six weeks you stepped up your
administration stepped up as well as
Congress and passing the PPP twice you
replenished it does more need to be done
to give a boost to the US economy beyond
what's already been done well I'm truly
grateful for the bipartisan support for
the relief for American families direct
payments that have all gone out to
Americans family of four receiving
$3,400 in a single payment as you
mentioned the Paycheck protection that
was recently expanded allows small
businesses around America to keep people
on the payroll for two months so that
they can retain that workforce and
people have the means while they're off
work we're also providing resources to
larger businesses that are critical
industries not only Airlines but hotels
and a broad range of businesses that are
at the core of our economy
can come through this and the presidents
made it clear we're gonna do whatever it
takes to see the American people
American families and American
businesses large and small through this
time but the most important thing we can
do is put the coronavirus behind us and
the good news is as the president
reflected just a few days ago we're
seeing great progress even in the areas
most profoundly impacted by the
coronavirus we're seeing stabilization
we're seeing a drop in hospitalizations
we're seeing a decline in cases and it's
it's all a testament to the American
people to their willingness to put into
practice the social distancing
guidelines that we unveiled 45 days ago
it's a testament to state leadership and
whether there is more to be done will
the president's said we're open to
additional support for states around the
country but for now the our primary
objective is to get America safely back
open get America back to work and put
the karana virus in the past you have
spoken about on a numerous occasions
about nursing facilities and the
devastating impact that this virus has
had on those facilities over 10,000 of
our most vulnerable population dying
because of the corona virus what more
needs to be done to protect the most
vulnerable in our society mr. vice
president well we learned early on that
the seniors with serious underlying
health conditions were especially
vulnerable to devastating medical
results with the corona virus and it's
one of the reasons why we we raise the
standards for every nursing home in
America it's the reason why we deployed
all 8,000 of our inspectors to ensure
infectious disease standards were
complied with in every state in the
country
we're surging resources developing care
packages right now to go to all 15,000
nursing homes in America but when you
look at the guidelines to open up
America again they include very specific
detail about focus
testing resources focusing attention
focusing social distancing and
countermeasures on our long-term care
and our seniors community I mean so long
as the coronavirus is with us we're all
gonna have to take special care of our
seniors particularly those with
underlying health conditions or anyone
with an immunodeficiency would you be
confident if you had a loved one in a
nursing facility right now that they're
getting not only the care they typically
would always get but also are being
protected from this deadly virus big
nursing homes around America truly done
a remarkable job under very difficult
circumstances I mean my mom is 85 years
young and she and my stepfather's still
living on their own I can't imagine how
tough it is for families not being able
to go visit a loved one so now you've
got nursing home caregivers that are not
only providing all the support they
provide every day but also filling in
for family in many cases and I must tell
you that while we while we've seen some
outbreaks in nursing homes we've
searched resources to deal with that
we've obviously seen heartbreaking loss
beginning in the first nursing home
incident in Seattle
I truly believe America's long-term care
facilities have stepped up and and have
met this moment and we're just going to
make sure they have the resources to
continue to keep their residents safe
finally mr. vice president talk about
some optimism that we got yesterday from
one of the president's health care
advisors dr. Anthony Falchi regarding
treatment for coronavirus what more can
you tell us about that
are you as optimistic as dr. Falchi
seemed to be yesterday well dr. Fauci
unveiled the news of a study of REM des
ver which is a therapeutic which we we
told the American people the president
pulled in all of the pharmaceutical
companies early on told him to go to
work on developing not only vaccines but
therapeutics which will give people
relief if they contract the coronavirus
and I know and now the FDA is
considering an emergency use
authorization to expand availability dr.
Fauci
reference that yesterday but I will tell
you that as the president's made clear
we're gonna meet use all means at our
disposal to bring medications to the
American people that will bring relief
and breakthrough with REM des affaires
is encouraging news it's a as the
president said it's a step in the
direction of treatment but the the
results from that study are truly
promising and and now we're gonna be
working to make that do you still feel
the beginning of June is the the time
when we'll get back to slowly our normal
lives the way they were back in January
before anybody even ever heard of
coronavirus I think if the American
people continue to practice social
distancing if they heed the guidance
particularly through any phased
reopening from their state and local
officials
I believe we could have much of this
coronavirus epidemic behind us by early
June but but it's going to take all of
us undoing everything that we need to
continue to do to get through this but I
have every confidence that we will and
as the summer goes forward we'll
continue to expand resources expand
testing work to develop therapeutics and
vaccines and and be ready for whatever
may come in the future mr. vice
president thank you for your time and
thank you for your invitation to join
you and your great state of Indiana
really appreciate it great to have you
here thanks
[Music]
this is guy Benson with your Fox News
commentary
coming up more businesses are opening in
more states with governor's making
decisions on what can open and with what
restrictions White House adviser Jared
Kushner tells Fox he thinks this will be
a transition month you'll see a lot of
states starting to phase and the
different reopening based on the safety
guidelines that President Trump outlined
on may on April 19th found out this week
the economy shrank 4.8% in the first
quarter of the year that includes really
just a couple of weeks of coronavirus
shutdown so the current quarters looking
worse president Trump predicts I think
next year is going to be an incredible
year for our economy I think the fourth
quarter is going to be really really
good will he even be president next year
I don't think that this president is
going to get blamed for the coronavirus
and the economic impact per se chris
wallace
is the host of Fox News Sunday my guess
is then that he will be judged by how he
handled it I mean this was a you know
natural occurrence that largely
unperceived is a stir it could have
happened to anybody but people will have
a sense by September or October did he
handle it as well as he could or didn't
he and I think one of the keys to that
and I think you're seeing it starting
right now is how quickly we reopen
there's a lot of divide in the
scientific community in the political
community in the economic community
about reopening and and you know that
there is the argument there as you say
one out of six Americans has lost their
job we there's a there's a tremendous
financial and psychic told to be paid
when when 30 million people are out of
work we need to get open again and then
they're resigned as who say you open
again too soon and people get too close
you could get a second spike and the
second spike will be even worse because
it'll really shake people's confidence
but there's anybody in charge I don't
know what's gonna happen you don't know
what's gonna happen but by September or
October we'll have a sense of what has
happened and and my guess is it'll be
that how that not the fact of the
coronavirus or the fact of
of this huge recession but how the
president handled it if he handled it
well as I've said before well myself if
he handle it well I don't see how he
loses if he had people proceed be
handled it badly I don't see how he wins
just anecdotally I'm hearing and seeing
anger at praise directed more at
governors than the president when it
comes to these reopening Zoar lack of
reopening some people in maine are mad
at Governor Janet Mills or they're happy
with Governor Janet Mills people in
Georgia are mad or happy with Brian Kemp
not President Trump I wonder if the
president if if the reopening stuff does
fall on individual governors and not the
president well yes or no I I certainly
agree I mean what you see in the polls
and it's fascinating is approval the the
most the highest ratings go to Anthony
flowey yeah you mean everybody thinks
he's you know he's the expert he's the
scientist and all he's concerned about
are the facts and and and then it goes
to governors and the president is is
down considerably from the governor's
and I think part of the feeling is that
the governor's have been driven more by
data and and it's been very interesting
with the president when he started
holding these briefings there was a
feeling of my gosh he's got two hours of
air time he's on all the networks Joe
Biden is stuck in a basement and in his
home in Delaware in a little you know
jerry-rigged studio this is a huge
advantage for the president but as the
briefings went on and they went off and
on they were often he went two hours and
the president would would start blaming
his political enemies and getting in
fights with reporters I don't think
there's any question that they there was
a back there backfired on them and that
there was a feeling that he wasn't
handling the crisis as much as he was
playing out all of his other's concerns
and grievances and getting praise and
all of that so again you know you could
argue that it's the governors who make
the decisions but in the end people are
gonna have to vote for president one way
or the other and I think that a lot of
it'll be a referendum on whether they
have confidence
maybe it comes down to this do I have
confidence that this is the guy I want
to lead the country and in handle any
particular crisis over the next four
years and Lord knows we don't have any
idea what those will be Joe Biden more
press is picking up the sexual assault
accusation from this former Senate
staffer what should he be doing here in
your opinion political reporters tend to
be I'm only half kidding about this
frustrated political advisors you know
we often think to ourselves gosh you
know if I were the candidate or I was at
his campaign manager I'd do it this way
I have a really strong feeling about
this and that is that that Joe Biden has
totally mismanaged this that that that
he's had a lot of women come out and
defend him a lot of women who
incidentally you know when I went to the
nail after Brett Kavanaugh back in 2018
and said women must be believed now
here's a woman and they're not they
don't want to believe her and and if i
dn't had denied it two weeks ago when we
were in this furor of the corona virus I
think would have been largely ignored
the story hadn't taught in his big and
people weren't paying as much attention
to Joe Biden now the story has built the
story of him failing to come forward and
and and and refuted and kind of hiding
behind women has grown so I think it's
you know I assume he's gonna deny it but
when he does I think he's gonna what
lost either much of the fact that it
would have been forgotten where much of
the benefit for coming forward and
confronting the allegations to be a
little callous because this is certainly
important as hair read I don't know how
much it matters politically because as
you mentioned all anybody wants right
now is to get out of this coronavirus
mess and also this the white-hot heat of
the start of the me to movement has also
passed maybe things would have been
different in anyway Biden's get the
nomination not not wrapped up so what
are we gonna do about it even if it is
true well and to be even more callous
you look at the two people that had the
biggest I'm talking about in sort of
political life allegations of me too
hence them first of all Donald Trump who
had not one but a dozen women come out
against him and had a videotape in which
he in his own words the the Access
Hollywood tape said all kinds of things
and he went on to win the election and
Brett Kavanaugh had this very
impassioned plea without almost any
evidence at all from cliff Christine
Blasi Ford but she was an effective
witness and he's on the Supreme Court so
you could also argue you know yes this
is embarrassing and yes it'll be tough
for him but in the end it isn't going to
affect Joe Biden's political fortunes I
you know should it well you know here's
an interesting thing about this the some
people are saying well god this is just
so terrible and all these women who said
women must be believed we should treat
Joe Biden and Tara Reid the same way I
disagree with that because I thought it
was the wrong way to treat Brett
Kavanaugh I don't think women should be
believe they should be heard and but
there's due process and if not in the
legal sense and Justin a justice sense
and if there's you know the fact that
she didn't have any evidence she didn't
have anybody who was a witness who said
yeah remember that I remember when it
happened and this happened and you told
me about it and you know it was
certainly an awful story but there was
no backup
other than her say-so and it seems to me
under those circumstances you can't you
can't find fault with a guy for that
well similarly with Joe Biden I wouldn't
say that Tara Reid should be believed
although I think she's got a much
stronger case than then Christine Blasi
Ford did because there are there's
evidence that she did contemporaneously
you know so her mother her brother some
of her neighbors all said that she told
them at the time so she's got a much
stronger case but I don't think in any
case any anybody should just be believed
they make an allegation well we don't
need to investigate there just to be
believed Kristin oh you're a big
baseball fan you heard about this plan
floated to break up the major leagues
for this one season into three regional
leagues to limit travel and get some
games in later in the summer
well I've heard versions of it and and
you know playing with it outside of
crowds in in Arizona and stuff I don't
know she it at a certain point does it
cease to be the game and the league and
the competition that you want I got with
our obviously baseball than not yeah but
it it almost feels meaningless to me so
I'm not sure how I feel about that yeah
might be a little weird to have games on
and hearing the crack of the bat but not
you know a single cheer well I've
thought about that you know cuz it don't
matter a lot of sports football
basketball baseball I mean you almost it
sounds terrible for a newsman to say
you'd almost want them to pipe in fake
sound because part of the fun of an
event is to hit you know I miss to hear
your team's go and the other teams going
down and your defense defense you know
you almost want to hear that so you know
if the only sound in a basketball game
is the squeak of the sneakers that's a
pretty lousy spectator of that yeah
maybe it works on TV better with golf or
NASCAR or maybe even I don't know maybe
that's about it perfect cuz all you need
is Jim Nantz saying hello friends and
and you know you fall asleep watching
that anyway so that would be perfect
yeah good nap viewing Chris Wallace host
of Fox News Sunday thanks again for
coming on talk to you soon you bet thank
you
[Music]
from the Fox News podcasts Network
download and listen to the untold story
with Martha McCallum the host of the
story on Fox News Channel sits down with
major newsmakers each week to get their
untold stories subscribe and listen now
by going to Fox News podcasts com Rayden
review the Fox News rundown on Apple
podcasts or wherever you listen and now
some good news with Tonya Jay powers
there are some good things happening in
the world
despite the corona virus pandemic that's
what it sounded like when dr. Karen o
midv re known as dr. o left Hackensack
University Medical Center this week he
was the 1,000th coronavirus patient in
New Jersey to be discharged from that
hospital he wasn't just a patient there
he also works as a pulmonologist in that
hospital's intensive care unit screening
patients for kovat 19 and became a
patient after he tested positive for the
virus in a video posted on the
hospital's Facebook page he was wheeled
out to the cheers of his fellow doctors
nurses and staff members wearing their
blue scrubs lab coats and masks and he
waved at everyone lining the path of his
exit dr. o is still recovering and has
participated in clinical trials as the
search for treatment and vaccine for the
corona virus continues Tonya J powers
Fox News
it's time for your fox news commentary
guy Benson what's on your mind a recent
story in The Washington Post detailed
the experience of a factory in
southeastern Pennsylvania the brass
competitor chemical plant where 43
workers volunteered to live at the
factory for 28 consecutive days they
worked in 12-hour shifts round-the-clock
for medical supplies like masks and
gowns for frontline health care workers
they were away from their families for
nearly a month no one left the plant
ever for any reason the country was in
trouble health care workers needed help
their plant produced critical materials
and they all raised their hands and said
we're gonna do it they finally clocked
out after 28 days on the job there are a
lot of Heroes being minted as this
country fights coronavirus and these
workers in Pennsylvania and many others
like them are doing incredible work with
no recognition god bless these people
and God blessed this country what a
story
this is guy Benson host of the guy
Benson show
[Music]
you've been listening to the box news
rundown and stay up to date by
subscribing to this podcast at FoxNews
podcasts calm and for up-to-the-minute
news go to Fox news.com
love FoxNews click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the FoxNews rundown
playlist for the latest episodes